we know what's going on right now um
basically the the laws the law the law
of the land is potentially being
overturned you know the supreme court
documents were leaked at what they're
talking about
oklahoma i think just banned abortions
completely or they're trying to like
straight up not even happening because
the debate is is it six weeks is it 12
weeks is it 18 weeks is it a state thing
is it a federal thing yeah um
and here's a um here's a quote from usa
today if roe versus wade is overturned
established rights like gay marriage and
contraception could be at stake the
slippery slope argument
i also there's a famous author these
days and he wrote
abortion is hypergamy i believe you
wrote that sir
i believe you wrote that crackpot some
guy
so also there's companies major
corporations out there starbucks being
one of them that became the latest
company to cover employees abortion
travel costs
okay and there's other companies that do
that so
ladies gentlemen i mean you want to
start with this rollo since you made
that comment abortion as i programmed
thoughts on this i've been saying this
since 2015 2014 something like that is
abortion is the
ultimate expression of hypergamy meaning
that there is no
uh there's no more permanent away that a
woman can exercise hypergamy than to
like end uh the guys like say you're not
the right guy and and is his genetic
legacy in utero right so what i ask is
this whenever this topic comes up like a
lot of people get very very emotional
and you have to separate the emotion
from the actual function of what why why
is it that women will fight tooth and
nail to keep safe legal abortion why is
that even such a
you know in a a country like ireland or
or argentina like catholic countries
over to you know overturn it and now you
can get an abortion in those countries
not just in those countries but
everywhere around the world everybody
celebrates it it's a big party time now
because now we can and of course what so
what happens is on the conservative side
you have a very emotional response which
is it's a moral ethical you know you
know god's going to damn you to hell
kind of thing on the liberal side it's
it's a it's emotional because it's a
woman's right to choose and it's it's
you know you're you're
men shouldn't be able to control a
woman's body that's how they cast the
whole thing and so it's a emotional
argument versus emotional argument and
somewhere in between there is rola
tomasi saying why is this such a big
deal why is this why is this even a
thing right now what's the function of
abortion and the true function of
abortion is it is a fail-safe against
bad reproductive choices that's what it
is to stop that that pregnancy from
proceeding
and don't give me the crap about oh what
about rape what about incest those
account for a fraction a minute fraction
of one percent of the of the abortions
that are performed in this country
that's where you need to start this
argument and too many guys are too many
people when they're having this debate
it's like it's god versus the the
godless liberals and it's like that's
not the point if you want to
conservatives if you want to win this
debate start from stats the stats are
there you have google just like i do
that's how i came to this right and so
if you go and you look at the the
reasons women give for abortion
something like 98 of them are elective
so that's they're they're getting them
because of choices that they are making
in their lives and you will hear like
famous actresses saying i got this
golden globe or this emmy because i had
three abortions and that set me up to be
able to do what i want to do kind of
thing it's like okay well that's you're
just making my point you're it is a a
fail-safe against you having gotten
pregnant and now you can get out it's
like a get out of jail free card it's a
mulligan exactly and so it's let's just
call it what it actually is and let's
also look at the stats let's also look
at the empirical objective stuff and
stop getting into this emotionalist one
emotionalism versus another emotionalist
because we have to see what is the
latent function what is the purpose of
of abortion and that's why i say
abortion is the ultimate expression of
hypergamy damn wow it's like that very
well yeah and it's like it's like you'll
win the argument if you just stay on the
stage the higher the value of the man
yeah the more likely are there they're
not gonna have the abortion if they got
[ __ ] up they slept with the guys kind
of like do you remember the story where
the drake hot sauce story
where uh the woman tried to
insert the used condom because she was
like i'm gonna do the exact opposite of
abortion that's a talk that's a tom
lycacism by the way it's like putting
hot tabasco in the in there what i'm
saying i'm more talking about the girl
that's the anti-abortion she's are you
trying to get impregnated
right by the drake or the nba thing
what's the one girl self-insemination pj
washington's girl yeah brittany ranner
brittany exactly okay and so like when
so when i'm talking about abortion i'm
talking about this kind of we can't get
away from it without also talking about
what are the why is that so imperative
because we live in a society that we
prioritize women's reproductive rights
uh mating strategies whatever we put
that at the top of the thing there and
you've got guys out and you know out in
the streets with their wives and their
girlfriends and pink [ __ ] hats you know
repeating the same thing over and over
and over again and again the only reason
we're even talking about this at this
stage is because we're in an election
year and nothing gets the ladies to the
polls like say you know claiming that oh
my god we're going to elizabeth warren
like losing our mind you know saying
we're going to lose roe v wade if we
don't get to the polls and vote for
democrats right so
everything's getting politicized when i
so when i see that and i look at like
say the the leak from what is the the uh
supreme court
and then you look at it it's like
it's you look at the the the
articles that have been written about
this they say oh they took a vote and
it's already been re you know you
wouldn't would think that they've
already overturned roe v wade no it was
a draft opinion by the supreme court of
the united states and it was leaked and
that was enough to spark all of this
conversation that we're having right now
and there's a threat that it might
happen
[Music]
you